[Farod] Pourquoi? Qu'est ce que je vois là?
[Fabien] Salut à tous et à toutes
zetà toutes
Salut !
il y a quelques temps sur Instagram et sur Twitter
j'ai partagé une illusion d'optique
que je ne connaissais pas et apparemment vous non plus
D'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à me rejoindre sur ces réseaux là
Alors aujourd'hui on va se faire une vidéo sur des illusions d'optique
que vous ne connaissez pas forcément
Il y en a 2-3 qui sont un petit peu célèbres
mais je pense que vous allez faire quelques petites découvertes
*accent du sud* pas dénuées d'intérêt
Pour faire la vidéo j'ai demandé à Farod
si il voulait venir, histoire de voir quelle réaction
lui il aurait face à toutes ces illusions là
C'est plus intéressant que juste vous les montrer
Et, il a dit oui
Merci à lui.
Gloire à Farod, dont vous pouvez retrouver la chaîne  dans la description
Et dans la description vous retrouverez, aussi, tous les fichiers que j'ai utilisés dans la vidéo
si vous voulez les télécharger
Avant de commencer la vidéo 2 informations rapides :
Avec First, qui est l'éditeur du livre, que vous avez ici
et que vous avez peut être déjà chez vous, sinon il y a un lien vers la description
On organise une tournée de conférences dans pas mal de villes en France
il y en a qui vont se rajouter, vous avez tout sur le site internet
www.fabienolicard.fr
et de toute manière j'en parle souvent sur twitter et Insta
et vous pouvez également réserver vos places pour l'Olympia l'année prochaine
le plus tôt sera le mieux
Parce que plus on sait le monde qu'il y aura, plus je vais pouvoir organiser des choses
Et maintenant je chausse mes petites lunettes et c'est parti
Je vais vous présenter et présenter à Mister Farod
des illusions d'optiques, qui pour certaines sont pas connues
[Farod] Ouais
[Fabien] D'autres sont un petit peu connues,
c'est-à-dire si tu t'intéresses à ça,
je suppose qu'il y en aura 2-3 que tu connaîtras
[Farot] Comme tout le monde, on a eu notre passage à l'école primaire
où l'on en a vu, dans les magasines ou quoi
et comme tout le monde on apprécie ça donc on cherche souvent à en avoir un peu plus
mais je ne suis pas à fond dedans donc...
je te demande de me faire découvrir un peu
[Fabien] On commence par celle-ci parce qu'elle est extrêmement connue
[Farod] *Rire*
[Fabien] La fameuse robe
[Farod] Ah oui, tu veux vraiment balancer le débat direct
[Fabien] C'est ça !
[Farod] Tu vas te taper des pouces rouges là, je te le dis *rire*
[Fabien] Alors elle est de quelle couleur cette robe? Pour toi?
[Farod] Alors pour moi visuellement je la vois bleu et une espèce de marron. Oui
[Fabien] Ouais et d'autres la voient blanche et or
[Farod] Ça me soûle déjà, non il y a pas de blanc c'est du bleu je suis désolé
[Fabien] Et sa vraie cou... alors tu sais que sa vraie couleur d'ailleurs c'est bleue et noire
il y en a peut être qui la voit blanc et or là
[Farod] Vas y dis moi comment ça se fait?
[Fabien] C'est juste une question du cerveau
si le cerveau se dit que la robe est éclairée par la lumière du jour alors
il interprète sa balance des blancs dans ton petit cerveau en mode blanc et or
Si il comprend que c'est de la lumière artificielle
il refait sa balance des blancs, comme ta caméra,
et il se dit c'est bleu et noir
Notre cerveau, il interprète le contexte
[Farod] C'est à dire que là il y a des gens qui la voient blanc et or
[Fabien] Oui sûr et certain. Oui
[Farod] Et bien manifestez vous alors. Je veux vous voir du coup
[Fabien] Et si tu veux la vérité, là je la vois bleue et noire
mais quand je l'ai imprimée ce matin je la voyais blanc et or sur le papier
[Farod] Là tu vois noire?
[Fabien] Ouais là je la vois noire
Pour le prochain, je vais te demander simplement de me dire ce que tu vois.
Comment ça s'appelle ce que tu vois?
Et vous aussi vous pouvez dire dans les commentaires ce que vous voyez. Evidemment. [Farod] Très bien
[Fabien] Donc ça, c'est quoi?
[Farod] Donc je vois des spirales d'un escargot
qui ... *onomatopée*
qui tombe jusqu'au centre
[Fabien] Jusqu'à l'infini?
[Farod] Jusqu'à l'infini
[Fabien] On est sûr que ça va jusqu'à l'infini ?
[Farod] Non, j'ai plus l'impression qu'il y a un point bleu au centre
Donc ça va s'arrêter mais c'est tout petit, donc je ne sais pas jusqu'où ça va.
[Fabien] Donc une spirale.
[Farod] Ouais.
[Fabien] Parce qu'en fait, il n'y a pas de spirale.
[Farod] Tu vas leur mettre la photo en bonne qualité ?
[Fabien] Ouais
[Farod] Comme ça je suis pas tout seul à réfléchir
[Fabien] Et si tu veux t'en convaincre,  tu peux faire le tour d'un cercle avec le doigt, vas-y
[Farod] Là c'est improbable par contre ce qu'il se passe
[Fabien] J'ai été obligé de faire ça, moi aussi
[Farod] Ah mais oui, d'accord. Mais j'arrive, enfin, je le trace mais je ne le vois pas en fait
[Fabien] C'est ouf ou pas ?
[Farod] Oui
[Fabien] Celle-ci, j'ai mis du temps moi aussi, à me dire... Au départ...
[Farod] Ah oui, là par contre, sur les grands je le vois.
[Fabien] Sur les grands ça va
[Farod] Mais sur les petits c'est n'importe quoi par contre
[Fabien] Juste avec des carrés blancs et noirs, on reprogramme toute la perception
[Farod] Mais tu sais qu'il y a moyen que je tombe malade, je rentre pas ce soir. Je vais me faire pourrir le cerveau...
[Fabien] J'ai préparé cette vidéo du jour où tu as bien voulu qu'on fasse ça ensemble. J'ai commencé à préparer et tout
A la fin de la journée, j'avais les yeux comme ça, j'en pouvais plus, j'avais mal au crâne
Tu vas kiffer
[Farod] Non mais surtout je vois ta pile de papier là qui est en train d'arriver, petit à petit
[Fabien] Que penses-tu de cette demoiselle ? Est-ce que tu la reconnais ?
[Farod] Ah, alors je suis très
mauvais pour euh...
[Fabien] Ben c'est pas grave, tu la reconnais pas ?
[Farod] Alors je suis désolé pour ceux qui la reconnaissent
Parce que du coup j'ai pas du tout une bonne culture
[Fabien] Tu la trouves comment ? Mignonne, pas mignonne ?
[Farod] Ben... Elle a l'air très maquillée
[Fabien] Très maquillée ?
[Farod] Très femme, on va dire, très femme
[Fabien] Ca peut faire partie des profils de filles qui te plaisent ?
[Farod] Je suis pas trop fan des filles qui se mettent du mascara en dessous de l'oeil en fait
[Fabien] Ouais, je vois *rires*
[Farod] Donc l'histoire c'est ça, c'est qu'elle a les yeux inversés ?
[Fabien] Et la bouche
[Farod] Ah oui d'accord !
[Fabien] Elle te plaît toujours ?
[Farod] Ben non, là du coup pas des masses
[Fabien] Beaucoup moins, hein ?
[Farod] On dirait... Je préfère pas citer de nom mais...
[Fabien] Est-ce que ce n'est pas horrible ?
[Farod] Alors, pour les yeux ça se capte, pour la bouche c'est assez dingue
[Fabien] Ca se capte avec la paupière, effectivement. Là, c'est assez simple, je pense que tu connais la réponse
[Farod] Oh pffff
[Fabien] Tu connais la réponse?
[Farod] Oui, je connais la réponse et je me suis déjà fait niqué dans ma tête
Evidemment, je les vois penchés entre eux tu vois. Celui là penche vers la droite, celui là vers la gauche
Et tu vas me dire qu'ils sont tous parallèles et complètement droits
[Fabien] Exactement
[Fabien] Et de la même manière...
[Farod] Avoue non, ils sont vraiment penchés
[Fabien] Eh non ! *rires* Ils sont penchés mec !
C'est tout, il n'y a pas d'illusion là-dessus ! Non mais c'est ça, et là on voit qu'à chaque fois avec le blanc et le noir
C'est l'entrelacement du blanc en fait qui fait croire ça mais ça y en a des centaines et des centaines
Ca, c'est un des moins connu, ce dessin là. Il faut vérifier en fait avec  le pattern qu'il y a derrière
[Farod] Si on regarde de loin, comme ça, ouais tu vois bien qu'il y en a un, au moins deux toujours, qui sont un peu penchés sur le côté
Mais c'est bien parce que chaque fois tu vas m'en sortir un, ça va me saoûler là je pense *rires*
[Fabien] Next ! Alors ...
[Farod] Après il va me sortir "t'as vu là les triangles, c'est pas des vrais triangles, c'est des ronds..."
[Fabien] D'ailleurs j'étais moi-même une illusion d'optique Farod!
[Farod] Tout dans mon décor est une illusion *rires*
[Fabien] Je te demande de me dire...
De me dire qui tu vois. Eux ils vont le voir aussi en même temps
[Farod] Je vois l'acteur de Harry Potter. Je vois Harry Potter
[Fabien]  Harry Potter, tout à fait. Ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'eux n'ont pas vu ça par contre
Est-ce que tu veux savoir ce qu'ils ont vu ?
[Farod] Tu veux dire que là je vais briser toute mon enfance ?
[Fabien] Ah c'est pas du tout Harry Potter
[Farod] Hein..... ok mais qu'es ce qu'il fout là lui : "Einstein"
[Farod] Heu...
[Fabien] c'est ouf ou pas ?!
[Farod] Tu as moyen de me le remettre de loin ?
[Fabien] Ouais!
[Fabien] Je te met même une deuxième personne si tu veux ?!
[Farod] Par ce que maintenant que je l'ai en tête je vais essayer de le voir du coup.
[Farod] Ok...
[Farod] Le Harry Potter je le vois toujours. C'est dingue ... c'est quoi..., c'est une histoire de..., les ombres des...
[Fabien] Tu as qui là ?
[Farod] Es-ce que ce ne serai pas...
[Fabien] Marilyn Monroe ?
[Farod] Mari... Mari... Marilyn Monroe
[Fabien] Oui c'est ça.
[Farod] Et de près tu vas m'apporter le visage d'une enfant je crois...
[Fabien] Non, toujours Einstein ! Je t'ai mis Einstein partout mon pote
[Farod] Ah ouais par contre c'est vraiment fort. Ils vont réussir à le voir ça en vidéo ou pas ? [Fabien] Ouais ouais complètement
[Fabien] Alors en vidéo, peut être juste avant que je reprenne cette phrase
Je vous les ai sûrement remis à des distances différentes
Je vous met le fichier dans la description si vous voulez l'imprimer chez vous et le faire